[Musique]
vous produisez normalement la première
semaine la deuxième semaine a diminué de
50% et la troisième on est à 1 25% et on
prévoit 30
comment découvrir des états unis cet
arrêté l'année dernière on a eu la
belgique il a arrêté fortement en même
temps que nous à lui le confinement on a
pratiquement perdu bâtiment 70% de deux
marches à l'époque on a emballé tous les
fromages qui sont stockés qui qu'on
essaye de vendre à moitié prix ou pour
écouler vraiment et produits
[Musique]
le problème c'est 80 de la production
laitière
on peut pas mettre le jeu match par des
lots aux combes est malheureusement donc
on est obligé de collecter le lait
quotidiennement ramat entre vingt et
vingt-cinq mille tous les jours et on a
demandé à nos producteurs de blé était
un petit peu leur production de lait
donc à tout bout de chaque producteur
mais entre 10% de leur collecte de leur
production laitière tutoie les
malheureux
[Musique]
imma be cette personne ce produit s'est
faite de matières aujourd'hui on n'a
aucune réponse nous avons des prêts de
l'état aux 15 annonce les reports des
charges d'impôts réellement on va après
pour financer ça et qu'on le fasse sur
plusieurs années ou si on risque d'avoir
de nature ans aujourd'hui en tête c'est
dur comme héros qui ferait tomber les
sentiers du principal
[Musique]
e
et